any one of these people who wants to
have Ukrainian flag and complain about
what's going on I say we send them right
over
you know like it's it's hard I do agree
that life has become treacherously dull
for people especially being lied to
about the military-industrial complex
and then realizing you're part of the
Empire is like what the what am I
doing I mean the reason they wouldn't go
to Ukraine is because they're like
languishing the fact that they know
they're useless like that's that's they
know that they that they would instantly
die their situation and that's like
demoralizing even worse
how much you want to bet winsinger that
story of you will live in the Pod you
will eat the bugs you will own nothing
and you will be happy they're probably
going please it can't come soon enough
they are they are I will tell you gen Z
has that attitude you know I in I see a
lot of the dialogue especially when
they're talking about you know if there
was an apocalypse they're saying wow you
guys will to live is incredible I just
let I'd let it all happen so I think
these kids are severely depressed I
think they don't really have much
purpose